.
- Des ballots de matièresmulent
par dizaines au centre de tri
de Lachine. L'entreprise Ricova,
qui exploite le site, n'arrive
pas à vendre ces ernational. Elé
la Ville qu'elle pourrait cesser
ses opérations.
VALERIE PLANTE, mairesse de Mtl
- Pour nous, c'est non.
service en matière de collecte
du recyclage.
- Montréal compte résilier
le contrat avec Ricova.
DOMINIQUE OLLIVIERexécutif, Vill
- C'était la piètre qualit
des ballots faits par Ricova
qui créait le problème initial.
résilier le contrat et qu'on a
cherché des nouveaux opérateurs,
on a cherché aussi une certaine
- Le centre de tri appartient à
la Ville et Ricova soutient que
l'équipement est inadéquat pour
répondre au volume de matériaux
recueillis à Montréal.
Mais l'entreprise est dans
l'embarras  depuis plusieurs
mois. En février, l'émission
les ballots avaient des taux
élevés de contamination avec des
En mars, le Bureau
de l'inspecteur général
recommandait à M
résilier le contrat avec Ricova.
ALAN DESOUSA, maire de l'arrond.
de St-Laurent, Ville de Montréaé
l'alarmeort et
maintenant, on est 6 mois plus
- Montréal assure que les
opérations de recyclage se
poursuivront sans interruption.
quatre centres de tri au Québec.
Elle devrait reprendre
le flambeau, mais ce ne sera pas
du jour au lendemain.
JEAN-SEB
- On n'a pas visitéles installa.
Donc ça peut prendre de quelques
semaines à quelques mois.
devrait conserver certains
de ses contrats ave
de Montréal, notamment ceux liés
à la collecte de matière
un autre centre de tri situé
dans le quartier Villeray/Saint-
Michel/Parc-Extension et
ici aussi, les ballots
de matières destumulent.
Ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon,
anada, Montréal.